Hello, how are you? Sali Jaramillo greets you
with the brief information for today, Tuesday
, March 9, as of today, more sites are
expanding their hours to vaccinate the
population, as
the Las Vegas Convention Center heard, it will have until
half past five in the  late for
eligible people, while the
Carmen Center will start until 6 in the
afternoon, other places will start
early, such as the main office
of the health district, starting at
seven in the morning. Health experts
are paying more attention to
vaccinate minorities in las vegas' the
director of the casa del
inmigrante foundation says that trust is the
main factor to receive the vaccine
this place together with walmart are
encouraging the latino population to get
vaccinated yesterday several people
received it without the need  from an appointment
without showing medical insurance,
legal immigration status and at no cost
according to the director this site gave 402
vaccinations on Sunday about  300 the day
before and they have been vaccinating
about a minimum of 2
people for the last two weeks one
of the most outstanding offensive players
of the riders is leaving the nfl
reports that the pro bowler 2019 after
round will go to the new
england patriots  where he started his career
these teams will work on
player signings next year however
brawn agreed to return to play for the
patriots and now we move on with your
weather forecast a
very windy day is expected the winds will be
40 to 50 miles  per hour the
temperatures will drop to 60 today and
tomorrow at 50 more there will be chances
of rain have a good day I am salt
and jaramijó and this was the Spanish edition
[Music]